[Musica]
1995 si era leoni west africa sono lì da
due anni è la mia prima missione insieme
a 6 con sorelle missionarie saveriane il
25 gennaio un gruppo di ribelli del ruf
fronte unito rivoluzionario fa irruzione
in casa nostra
è mattina presto ci prendono fuori così
è guerra civile la nostra situazione
cambia in un batter d'occhio da gente
che poteva aiutare persone in bisogno
soprattutto bambini disabili ci
ritroviamo immediatamente impotenti a
rischio della vita noi stesse
non possiamo più far niente siamo in
balia di gente che ti può ammazzare da
momento all'altro sono in mezzo violenze
indicibili fatte a bambini ragazzi donne
intere famiglie massacrate villaggi
bruciati saccheggiati ora siamo
prigionieri di guerra
siamo alle spie del governo nemico siamo
merce di scambio per far parlare i media
o magari per un riscatto
la preghiera è costante non rimane altro
anche in quel buio preghiamo padre
nostro
sì anche per i ribelli perché ci
guardiamo intorno e quei ribelli li
vediamo che potrebbero essere i nostri
fratelli
siamo davvero la stessa famiglia umana
gli estremi confini della terra e un
cuore che non riesce più a mare che è
stato violentato
sono stati violentati a loro volta no se
si trovano in un campo così ma anche in
una situazione estrema del genere ci
sono dei gesti di una delicatezza
incredibile
una ragazza ci viene vicino era molto
rischioso per loro era una donna dei
ribelli
noi eravamo affamati ci davano solo
della roba che era già corrotta in quel
caldo e ci porta una tazza di riso e
fagioli niente per sette persone
affamate si avvicina a noi quasi si
inginocchia con rispetto
noi facciamo solo tempo a chiedere ma
come ti chiami e lei dice my name is
morsi il mio nome è misericordia quel
nome è davvero un messaggio per noi un
altro ragazzo molto giovane per il
sospetto remo va a rubare trova una
pianta di cassava ne prende il tubero
cielo porte come mangiare una patata
cruda
eppure dice sisters mi dispiace per voi
che sa quanto soffrite lontano dalla
famiglia
noi in qualche maniera ci sono abituati
a questa vita però e aggiunge gode che
vuol dire in sierra leone se dio c'è dio
sa è davvero commovente anche in questo
ragazzo la capacità di consolare noi ma
come fanno a resistere in questo in
queste situazioni dei gesti di
benevolenza così da dove nascono come
sopravvivono il bene come un piccolo
seme piantato nel nostro cuore da chi ci
vuole bene
all'inizio è nascosto agli occhi si
nutre di umiltà di sacrificio di sé
però se lo curi lo nutri cresce diventa
un amore grande vero e forte forte più
forte della violenza e la vince sempre
il bene vince il fracasso della
cattiveria in silenzio come un piccolo
germoglio buca l'asfalto il bene vince
la complicata rete
del male con un solo gesto di carità
gratuita
il bene vince le distanze perché ti
mette nei panni dell'altro ti fa capire
quanto l'altro sta soffrendo non importa
come e dove
e questo piccolo gesto ha una potenza
enorme in sé non costa nulla a chi lo
dona
eppure è un preziosissimo per chi lo
riceve
perché dona speranza di un'amicizia e
tutti noi possiamo farlo tutti noi
abbiamo già ricevuto questo dono e tutti
noi possiamo donarlo non ci costa niente
ed è prezioso per chi lo riceve e tutti
noi possiamo donarlo perché il bene
siamo noi
sei tu con la tua vicinanza la tua
presenza la tua amicizia che soffre e
c'è una matematica paradossale nel ben
più lo moltiplica lo più lo condividi e
più lo moltiplichi e questa cosa succede
dappertutto nel mondo
anche nella mia terza missione dopo
harland di nuovo sono andati in
thailandia in thailandia sono stata 16
anni il background e buddista tera vada
lì la povertà la malattia alla miseria
la disabilità sono considerati il karma
sono una punizione giusta per un male
che tu devi aver fatto nella vita
precedente davis contare
ho lavorato con persone povere disabili
nelle baraccopoli di bangkok della
periferia queste come watson l'on
la baraccopoli dove io vivevo qui sono
delle stradine sopraelevate sotto è
tutto un acquitrino pieno di sporcizia
di rifiuti la gente stessa che vive lì è
considerato un rifiuto
eppure ci sono delle perle rare questo
enit e un bambino che è nato dalla mamma
era in carcere per droga
abbandonato poi sia dalla mamma che dal
papa era lì vicino alla stanzetta dove
io vivevo a poco a poco mi hanno accolto
io stesso poi non mi sentivo meglio di
questa gente
se noi avessimo avuto una storia come
queste persone che vivono lì saremo
forse la stessa cosa e nella baraccopoli
siccome il lavoro aumentato tantissimo
sono infermiere fisioterapista andava a
trovare persone ammalati di aids allo
stadio terminale non le volevano neanche
in ospedale perché dichiarare l'aids in
thailandia a tagliare le gambe al
turismo e allora il padre che era con me
mi ha dato delle persone ed aiutarmi e
sono persone che poi ho ritrovato quando
si è aperta la casa degli angeli mamme
di bimbi disabili o persone disagiate
ecco tra queste mamme che vengono quasi
tutti da queste situazioni di povertà di
miseria
chen yuan una giovane donna che è andato
a 16 anni di carcere per spaccio di
droga e quando è uscita non sapeva dove
andare a lavorare poteva andar se
vendere e allora viene con me ad
aiutarmi con i malati terminali di aids
non le faceva schifo niente perché aveva
passato ben cose ben peggiori
no anni era libera libera di perderci la
faccia non aveva niente da difendere
quanto mi ha insegnato prima spacciava
droga poi si spacciava per la moglie di
gente ammalata di aids
quindi sì si passava lei per essere
malata e dei dietro ma questo lo faceva
con una intuite un sorriso incredibile
per evitare al malato di dear tutta la
storia dolorosa di raccontarlo
nell'analisi e poi li strizzava l'occhio
come di recente in diamo poi la
preferivano a tutti aveva sul voglia di
far bene poi mi ha seguito alla casa
degli angeli e quando è stata lì ha
voluto essere mamma diceva sisters io
non ho figli miei qua voglio fare la
mamma ai bambini che non hanno
la mamma il papà e son disabili e li
caricata sulle spalle con tutta la
fatica è tutta la generosità che solo
lei poteva in mezzo a queste donne c'è
anche gift una ragazza madre
il bambino era sano il marito non ha
sopportato il pianto del bimbo era
buttato per terra la famosa shake and
baby syndrome
il bimbo è diventato gravemente disabile
lei quando è venuta la casa degli angeli
perché la dottoressa ci ha chiesto per
favore prendetela è troppo pericoloso
per le per il bimbo stare là col suo
compagno le venuta ma avrebbe voluto
scappar via di lì dice non voglio stare
più con tutte donne e bambini disabili
eppure c'è stato un momento in cui lei
avrebbe avuto la possibilità aveva un
ragazzo te lo andava a trovare il retto
allora sei pronto per farti una famiglia
di nuovo e di cielo già lasciato detto
cosa è successo
cioè mi ha detto lascia cui il bambino
alla fase degli angeli tu vieni con me e
te e tu cosa hai risposto e gli ho detto
non sono un cane per abbandonare il mio
bambino e venire con te davanti una
adolescente che poteva sembrare
sfrontata pretenziosa andava via un po
no non voleva essere comandata da
nessuno eto'o pensate quanto bene c'è
nel cuore di una persona quando noi meno
ce l'aspettiamo neanche lei ho imparato
abbracciare tutta la vita di una persona
non solo guardando l'esterno ma quel che
c'era e gli ho detto ma chi t'ha dato la
forza di un gesto così le ha detto il
mio bambino e da ultimo lin linee era
una persona che è stata era orfana di
mamma se poi sposata con sposata
accoppiata con suo marito hanno avuto
una bimba la bimba è diventata disabile
per un'operazione andata male
lei ha servito la bimba un anno e mezzo
è rimasta incinta di nuovo ma il marito
appena lei ha partorito il bimbo l'ha
abbandonata non l'hai lasciato niente in
casa e avrebbe voluto togliersi la vita
non ne poteva più mi ha rintracciato
dice esiste non ne posso più
e ha detto vieni qui non ti preoccupare
avevo paura timore a dirle aiutaci con i
nostri bimbi disabili sapevo che lei
lavorava da dio proprio con questi bimbi
lei senza neanche aspettare più glielo
proponesse si è messa a curare i bimbi
come avrebbe curato la sua piccola o può
che era morta e a un certo punto dice io
qui ho incontrato l'amore vero
e c'è anche con mio marito mi accorgo
che avevamo come due corpi vicini ma non
era vero amore
io voglio conoscere di più voglio
conoscere gesù voglio andare al
catechismo voglio prendere il battesimo
suo marito si ripresenta e lei ha avuto
il coraggio di dirgli guarda io sono
disposto a tornare conta non ci ho mai
tradito
c'è però tu devi accettare che io voglio
conoscere questo amore non posso tornare
conta è come prima come due corpi vicini
ma ci torno in questo nuovo modo questa
donna che ha perdonato l'imperdonabile
perché quella con cui lui l'ha tradito
era la migliore amica di entrambe e ha
dato nelle mani del suo marito il
bambino facendolo chiamare papà che lui
non lo conosceva neanche cio pensando
alla storia di queste persone mi accorgo
di quale ricchezza sono state per me
questo germoglio di ben il loro è
cresciuto fino a davvero a sbocciare un
giorno venendo fuori dalla baraccopoli
l'occhio mi cade su un fiore bello mai
visto primo trovato una foto ma non era
proprio così ma comunque dice la radice
del fiore affondava nella melma nera e
maleodorante della baraccopoli mai share
era bellissimo cielo il sole che vi
battevano con la rugiada stupendo
profumava perfino avevo mai visto
immediatamente ho pensato a tutta la
gente che ho incontrato al campo dei
ribelli nella baraccopoli alla casa
degli angeli queste donne ne ho detto
anche loro sono come questo fiore
davvero sono nate e cresciute nel fango
nella mail neppure sono riuscite a
sbocciare fino a diventare persone
capace di ben e di perdono di amore
gratuito di amore anche per un altro
bambino
chi di noi sarebbe riuscito a fare
questi passi da gigante con una storia
così dietro era davvero queste sono le
bolden brilliant people che ho voluto
condividere con voi oggi per capire come
davvero non c'è situazione così
impossibile in cui noi stessi non
possiamo condividere e far sbocciare un
fiore dalla melma più nera anche della
nostra vita oggi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]